welcome to the show it's a new week it's
a new day and it is not a new world in
terms of what's going on with
coronavirus it's much the same as what
was going on last week worse in some
places and yet Donald Trump had a rally
he did it
6,200 people showed up in Tulsa Oklahoma
not the sixty-two thousand that Donald
Trump predicted they didn't really have
1 million people trying to go as Donald
Trump's campaign manager claimed but we
will get to all of that and we're going
to spend some time today talking about
the different aspects of this rally
because there are so many stories and
types of stories and because they're so
emblematic of much of what is wrong with
the United States of America right now
so we're going to go through step by
step how Donald Trump's rally was
overhyped they claimed a million people
wanted to go they got 6,200 it was
irresponsible Oklahoma is a coronavirus
hotspot six Trump staffers sent in
advance to set up for the rally tested
positive chock-full of ignorant people
was the rally people who vote and we're
going to talk about the issue of anti
intellectualism in the United States and
the content of the rally itself riddled
with horrifying admissions from Donald
Trump each of which would be a scandal
in a normal administration so I'm going
to get to crowd size in that part I'm
going to get to the public health
component I'm going to get to interviews
with some of the attendees we're going
to get to all of it but we have to start
with what the president said during the
rally and what Trump said during the
rally was illustrative of just how
triggered Donald Trump truly is because
of the things that people say on the
Internet about him Donald Trump during
this rally spent more than 20 minutes
just on his water drinking and ramp
walking problems and Trump's actual
speech also shed light on the reality
that Trump has no real 2020 campaign
message and this is something I also am
going to talk about a little bit later
things aren't good so Trump can't really
campaign on things being good unless he
lies which he has no
problem doing and to some degree he has
been but the attacks on Biden are mostly
ad hominem so you've got no real message
attacks on your opponent our ad homonyms
we have 20% real unemployment and there
is no actual case being made for his
reelection and that was very much
represented during this rally it was one
of the most jingoistic and self-centered
xenophobic ignorant horror shows that
I've seen in politics for a long time
and let's get into just a couple of the
specifics of what Donald Trump said now
this is this is a borderline criminal
admission that Donald Trump made it's a
murderous admission Donald Trump
admitted during the rally that he asked
for testing to be reduced to be slowed
down because he knew if we tested more
we would find more cases this is
borderline criminal this leads to deaths
it is murderous take a look at what
Donald Trump admitted to test of what
you do testing to that extent you're
gonna find more people you're gonna find
more cases so I said to my people slow
the testing down please they test then
they test we had tests the people don't
know what's going on we got this we got
another one over here I really need
people to understand testing saves lives
this is tantamount to murdering people
deliberately it's not all we've been
struggling and we just haven't yet
gotten testing where we wanted this is
Trump saying the disaster of testing was
partially he was asking for testing to
be held back and the White House later
realizing the degree of insanity that
this is the White House later said it
was a joke there was no indication that
it was a joke
this is not something to even joke about
obviously and please understand that
testing finds more cases like in the
short term okay if we don't do any tests
today we don't find any cases today but
testing identifies people who shouldn't
be going out it slows the spread and in
the long run more testing reduces cases
the more testing you do over the long
run the number of people who are testing
positive should decline
it is murderous to suggest do less
testing now Trump then again pulled out
this perjorative name for coronavirus
kung flu during the rally you could tell
he was sort of manic from the crowds
energy despite it being a far smaller
crowd than he was anticipating clearly
still hopped up from the crowd and
throwing kung flew out there it's a
disease without question has more names
than any disease in history I can name
come flu I can name 19 different
versions of them so the crowd cheering
and in particular you see one woman
behind Trump who sort of raised her fist
and a sign of victory I guess at Trump
calling the virus come flu certainly a
Pyrrhic victory if nothing else then
Trump drank from a glass of water and
the crowd went wild
now that sounds weird it is weird think
about how low the bar is that Trump
drinking out of a glass of water with
one hand I guess to prove his critics
that he's able to do it he got a
standing ovation that is how low the
expectations are take a look Trump
drinking water throwing the glass aside
and the crowd goes absolutely wild and I
don't want to get water on the time and
I don't want to drink much so lift it up
the water I see we have a little glass
of water where the hell did this water
come from where did it come from and I
look down on my tie because I've done it
I've taken water and it spills down and
you type does it look good for a long
time and frankly the tie is never the
same so I put it up to my lip and
understand because I know I didn't have
just a case and they gave me another
disease
they gave me another disease
this is a very very sick guy I said
Trump doesn't have a 20/20 message maybe
the messages I can drink water with one
hand and they think that that that will
be better than what Joe Biden is
offering maybe they're right we'll know
in four and a half months but what a
time to be alive
twenty minutes spent rambling about how
he can walk down add ramp ramp and drink
water with with a single hand so it was
genuinely disgusting and also as I said
representative of so many of trumps
problems no message no vision a
disjointed speech in a red state that he
easily won and still unable to fill
barely a third of the 19,000 seat seats
in the arena and we are supposed to
believe that there is any reasonable
case to reelect this guy well that's
what I'm going to tackle next because
we're going to look at interviews with
Trump supporters at the rally and what
you will hopefully quickly realize is
that when these are your supporters
maybe you don't need the facts on your
side to justify reelection when these
are your supporters maybe it doesn't
matter that you have no case for your
own re-election let's talk about that
next one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending
you can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
I love using free trials because I know
I won't be charged when the trial is
over if I use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private by not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman